hello ladies and gents more name's Ryan
Roy I'm Brianna white hey yeah we'll
play long master alien Mortal Kombat X
Kombat pack 2 here there's some new
characters being revealed normally don't
cover games but Brianna's gamer and I
was like you know what let's bring
Briana on for this I wonder who's in it
I wonder who's in it
a Leatherface
we got the xenomorph
that looks so badass to xenomorph looks
terrifying
Leatherface really cool Leatherface oh
dude that's exciting exciting I think
those other characters are reoccurring
or characters brought back from other
video games and bless you bless you may
God bless you may Jesus bless you
may not've bless your dick Gandhi bless
you I bless you and I bless all of you
peace be with you and also with you may
God bless you may Jesus bless you
think you're making it worse bless you
may yo de pusi Mortal Kombat X is
getting all these like cool downloadable
characters I mean there would include
Jason they already included the predator
I would like to see some other additions
in there I like to see like the t1000
from Terminator 2 or did gorgeous Arnold
Schwarzenegger 38-hundred this is the
exoskeleton
I think spawn from the comic books would
be cool
I think ash from Evil Dead would be cool
okay so yeah I feel like there'd be a
lot of really [ __ ] cool characters
you can get in there Leatherface looks
[ __ ] terrifying yeah he does is he
just come in my knight comes after you
with that chains all ready to [ __ ] you
up and a xenomorph ooh alex creepy that
was the best reveal ever yeah I just
came through the chest oh so cool I came
on the chest before remember who you
were gonna go there have written because
you said came on I'm just really good at
setting you up for these thank you thank
you thank you you do you set it up you
know what I mean as a stretch
well sometimes you guys stretch it out
Martin the pumping guy anyway guys
listen if you're new to the channel
subscribe today become a reject
Brianna white gaming channel check it
out cool channel
Damien Reaper I'm gonna give this guy a
shout-out he didn't ask for one but he
put a comment that I really loved a lot
YouTube channels slash internet shows
I like real rejects Tyrone finebros
angry joe markiplier angry joe fellows
don't arouse them you're all reactors
taking your reactions and creating
content that's entertaining your show
Ryan's has sketches full movie reviews
commentary it either being serious
subject or sex jokes you have the
makings of a talk show host very Conan
like I do wish you react to I [ __ ]
love Christmas by the Nostalgia Critic
maybe I don't know about that buddy
Damien Reaper uh Thank You Man
the fact that you said very Conan like
as Conan is my hero
I love Conan O'Brien yeah yeah I love
freckles I just below his knees here
freckles I don't love everything about
coming so funny I love to go on a show
my gosh lovely on show one day cool
exactly I have a photo in that I'm
actually see nut
yeah bang created a meet guest starring
on Conan then it was really realistic
Conan's like force many blow him yeah
I'm like you know it's like I'm into
that that when he's like forcing me to
blow him right I'm just like really yeah
yeah make me beg for it maybe choke on
mmm-hmm you know definitely goods
I choked on Conan's dick gag and
everything I would want Conan to clone
himself so I could have two of Conan's
dicks in my mouth that's a lot of Conan
yeah by the way I'm trying to get
sponsorship for pornhub.com if you're
watching thank you know